it's time to make some meatballs because
what's more italian than some meatballs
hey everyone i'm chef joe sasto and
today i'm going to be turning one of
these mystery ingredients into pasta
well we have some crazy options here
let's find out what i'm making today
all right all right chipotle burrito i'm
okay with that one it's not too hard
it's not the easiest option on here
let's just get started i think first
things first we need to order some
chipotle
and we have our chipotle so we got the
whole thing obviously some chips salsas
we'll include those i have some ideas
the ideas are flowing i know how to work
those into the mix right we got
a healthy
portion of crema thank goodness because
that actually is my favorite part
and wow a very tiny
burrito am i crazy did they used to be
much bigger than this let's open this up
we'll give it a little a quick bite a
taste test
okay we got steak beans and rice i have
all these on the side i'll use
everything just to keep it fair
this is gonna be good i know what to do
we got this let's make some
pasta first things first we need our
pasta dough now i've never done this
before obviously i've made quite a bit
of pasta dough but my instincts tell me
to use the rice in the dough so we're
gonna go our burrito rice
into here i'm gonna give it a little bit
of flour just to get it started
i'm using double zero
and semolina
a little of this a little of that
all right i got just a little bit of
room temperature water here
all right
that is the beginning of our pasta dough
i am going to use the rest of this flour
and the rest of this flour
and of course you know a little bit of
salt goes a long way and making
everything taste better slowly adding in
some water
voila huh
how about that
who would have thought you can turn
chipotle burrito rice into pasta dough
time to knead i'm gonna take just a
little bit of flour here just to make
sure we're not gonna stick
i already could tell right now i'm gonna
use this to make some cavitelli i don't
think that's ever been done before first
time ever things are happening here and
you're watching it you're part of it
pasta dough is done let's get this
wrapped up
and break down the rest of that burrito
for the rest of our pasta
so i need to incorporate the burrito
tortilla here some way so i'm just going
to go ahead and cut this into
some thin strips so butter is hot nice
and sizzling
we'll come in with our
tortilla strips a little pinch of salt
and our chipotle powder for our chipotle
burrito chipotle smoked dried jalapenos
for anyone out there that was wondering
most chilies have two names a name when
they're fresh and the name when they're
dried interestingly enough so i'm just
gonna let my crumble rumble i'm gonna
throw this into the oven let it get nice
and crispy and then it's time to make
some meatballs because what's more
italian than some meatballs
so i have my steak here from my chipotle
burrito we'll start with a little bit
of olive oil
some onions we'll start with a little
sofrito here diced onions some chopped
garlic we'll sweat this down onions and
garlic cooked down nice soft and
translucent and we'll go in
with all that steak i got a little bit
of smoked
paprika here let's just toss this all
together toss toss toss
that looks and smells awesome
so i'm going to let this cool in the
fridge i'm going to grab my tortilla
chips and then we're going to turn it
all into meatballs
now i want to grind these down into
breadcrumbs except it's not bread
they're going to be tortilla chip crumbs
for our meatballs
i'm probably only going to use
we'll use that many
all right so steak now into our tortilla
crumbs
into here instead of ground beef
now we need uh let's see an egg
this is gonna be our binder
hold everything together
we're on our way
look at that that is that's meatball-ish
taste test
make sure we like our seasoning
[Music]
gloves
on time to form some meatballs i'm going
to use a little scoop here just to keep
things nice and consistent now i'm just
going to come through here
make these all nice and pretty the true
testament of this is at the end when
we're tasting it if they can't tell that
we started with a chipotle burrito i
think we accomplished our mission a
little more olive oil into a hot pan
there's no raw meat in here so really i
just want to crisp them up on the
outside
get a little bit of color we're just
going to let these guys finish cooking
all the way through and then we're
cooking some pasta
for a sauce i'm going to uh incorporate
the pinto beans that i had picked out of
my burrito from earlier i'm also going
to supplement that with a little bit of
vegetables over here starting with a hot
saute pan we're going to go in with a
couple of tablespoons of butter
this butter makes things taste better
melt that down bring it together we have
some diced onion we got some diced
carrot
ready to
incorporate our
beans and then
we have this pico to use right so we'll
do a little bit of
that tomato in there toss that all
together to combine
and then i do want to kind of cook this
down together make this all become one
this is beef stock and so i'm just going
to cover everything with a little bit of
stock
we'll bring this up to a simmer reduce
it just a little bit and then we're
going to throw it all into the blender
until it's nice and smooth so our
bean rag goo has reduced to about half
here now i just want to blend it all
together and we'll have a nice smooth
and creamy
bean sugar
let's give it a little
taste test for approval we're nice and
smooth creamy
oh
no one's gonna know this is a chipotle
burrito i don't even know it's a
chipotle burrito i'm gonna season this
up with just a little squirt of lime
juice
then it's time to roll out some pasta
i'm just going to divide this
into let's call it sixths
i know math is hard
then those will be ready i'm going to
come in here and take each strip
and roll it
we might need the spray bottle
there we go now we're rolling i'm
italian i'm allowed to do this right
so those are all done i got all of my
snakes finished
going to take my flower now and just
dust that over the top
so snakes are together then we can come
in with our cutter i like to go in half
and go down the row
pasta magic
happening right before your eyes
that's not it now we have all of our
cavitelli
almost
then you come in here and i'm going to
use a uh cavarolo board just to put a
little bit of texture in that
notorious little cup
on each piece of pasta and then we're on
to the moment of truth we've all been
waiting for time to cook this and bring
it all together
[Music]
so we got all of our rice chipotle
cavitelli noodles
one of a kind
maybe the one and only time this will
ever be done perfect lid back on so
we're boiling
so noodles are floating here we'll give
it a little
much more fluffy
than i would have imagined really nice
texture on those
that's pleasant i like that
what a fun surprise huh our noodles are
done
into our meatball pan
a little bit of that pasta water
always our friend some starchy water we
call that the white gold
i have our bean sugar from earlier
we'll go one nice spoonful of that
and now hear that sound
sound a good pasta my friends huh
so we'll go pasta down first
in our bean ragu
let's go crema creme's next right
oh my look at that
next our meatballs
coming in
next
a little bit of our cilantro
for freshness
we have our crispy crumbly tortilla
strips
what a beautiful looking bowl of pasta
made from a chipotle burrito now we just
got to bring in our taste tester alex
welcome
you're back for more i have another
pasta here for you
smell test that's great
kind of smells like beans
you're good yes yes you're on the right
track
i like this
[Music]
sauce
you're a good bite builder that's a good
bite
this tastes like mexican food yes you're
on the right track it's fast food like a
burrito bowl
close
i mean it's a burrito
from chipotle
yes you are a star you're so creative
thank you for watching i want to know
let me know in the comments what i
should make into pasta next can i eat it
and we'll have alex here forever to try
i'm eating all of your pasta the
ultimate judge
i'm okay with being a judge oh yes
[Music]
you